y cientos de flores en la entrada de la
escuela y carteles en homenaje al
profesor de historia y geografía
asesinado vecinos padres y alumnos
rindieron homenaje a samuel para ti
remy de 11 años cuenta que su clase de
sexto grado fue la última en tener
contacto con él
estaba un poco en shock con lo que dicen
en la televisión no me lo esperaba en
absoluto salí de la escuela y diez
minutos después murió
los que recuerdan a patti hablan de una
persona buena y cariñosa el maestro de
47 años y padre de familia era un hombre
tranquilo apasionado por su trabajo y
sin antecedentes según quienes lo
conocieron
era un hombre discreto por lo que nunca
hubo controversia sobre él
en la ciudad de decenas de profesores
también rindieron homenaje gracias a una
movilización organizada en línea
la investigación del servicio nacional
antiterrorista entregó los primeros
elementos la identidad del atacante fue
confirmada se trata de un joven de 18
años nacido en moscú y de origen
checheno los servicios de inteligencia
no lo conocían por radicalización pero
sí por pequeños delitos por los que
nunca fue condenado el hombre había
obtenido un permiso de residencia de
diez años y poseía el estatus de
refugiado en francia uruguay tus nietos
inmediatamente después de los hechos se
publicó un mensaje de reclamo en una
cuenta de twitter llamada a lanzar
chiche n270 acompañado de una macabra
foto de la víctima futura kabul una
víctima hasta ahora 11 personas han sido
detenidas entre ellas familiares del
agresor y padres de alumnos del colegio
de confianza antón orina